la réussite n'est pas réservé à l'élite
à ceux qui naissent avec la cuillère
d'argent dans la bouche mais bien tout
jeune à sa chance tout je ne peux
réussir à travers un projet de création
d'entreprise à travers une activité ça
peut être n'importe quelle activité ça
peut être de la peinture de la culture
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous devons
faire comprendre aux jeunes que la
réussite est à leur portée et que
l'échec ne constitue qu'une étape vers
la réussite est souvent la réussite est
au bout
mesdames et messieurs bonjour à l'infini
comme partout ailleurs comme vous pouvez
le constater la pole au niveau de
pollution mondiale ne cesse de croître
et là et le plastique n'a pas d'humour
de plats dans cette pollution
c'est pourquoi en janvier 2020 une loi
visant à interdire l'utilisation du
plastique sera appliquée cependant le
plastique est utilisé dans notre
quotidien et il a donc fallu trouver une
alternative à celui ci cette alternative
peut-elle être économiquement viable
la réponse est oui et c'est ce que nous
allons découvrir autour de cette
présentation biopic n est une mini
entreprise de quatre personnes elle a à
sa tête in directrice marketing
accompagné d'une directrice
administrative et comptable d'une
directrice technique et moi même des
ressources humaines elle a pour
principale activité la conception et la
commercialisation de contenants à base
de bagasse
alors mesdames et messieurs tout au long
de cette présentation nous avons mis en
avant nos bouteilles nos produits mais
nous tenons aussi à nous mettre en avant
quand il nous a fallu du temps de la
patience de la détermination du coeur
oui cette passion commune qui nous a
permis d'être ici présents devant vous
on a dû faire beaucoup de sacrifices et
on s'est découvert et on s'est découvert
de nouvelles capacités
c'est vraiment incroyable de voir à quel
point on peut se dépasser lorsqu on a
vraiment eu envie de réussir et la
passion pour notre projet
norman diplômé d'un master de commerce
cette gestion se lance dans la
transformation du poisson tels que le
new des caraïbes antar ou rillettes
[Musique]
les loups sont bien là mais
en mal n'y est pas il semble que la
pêche soit des jeunes philip norman a
rejoint la berge pour l'activité c'est
de la transformation produits de la mer
donc on récupère les poissons et les
fruits de mer auprès des pêcheurs
aquaculteurs de la martinique ou qu'on
puisse y est transformé en filet dans
cette équipe avait de poisson on va
faire aussi du poisson fumé dans le
nouveau local
ils sont revendus en majorité aux
restaurateurs et d'autre part aux
particuliers le but c'est serait
d'arriver à faire des produits un peu
plus transformé avec une transformation
en produits finis c'est à dire des
rillettes des beurs de poissons et
d'autres mais bon ça c'est par la suite
ça va venir avec un peu dès que
l'entreprise sera un peu plus installée
parce que ça demande encore des
investissements un peu plus cher donc
oui c'est là c'est le but premier
mais on y arrive on y arrive ça va
demander un peu de temps dans
l'investissement du travail c'est comme
ça c'est gérer une entreprise c'est
comme ça il faut faire confiance aux
jeunes parce que ces jeunes là où
représente notre futur c'est eux qui
devront assurer la relève
parce que souvent j'entends des jeunes
dit ouais mais monsieur les adultes ne
font pas confiance
donc lorsqu'on leur fait pas confiance
en eux mêmes n'ont plus confiance en eux
ce qui est important c'est de faire
comprendre aux jeunes qu'il a sa propre
valeur ajoutée il est nous avons
différents il est de la génération
facebook il est dans la génération
instagram c'est vrai que c'est différent
il ya des modèles de communication qui
ne sont pas les mêmes il ya un mode de
fonctionnement qui n'est pas le même
mais l'objet reste toujours le même
c'est comment on arrive à créer une
continuité dans la société et cette
jeunesse là est censé assurer la relève
et nous donne
la préparer pour assurer cette relève le
vrai travail
si la réflexion du jeune martiniquais du
martiniquais tous co qui va tout faire
ou que ce territoire soit une réussite